in my talk at the table two men from the
bronx
who were changing the late night comedy
scene big time jesus nice
and the kid mural have interviewed
everybody from chris rock to dr anthony
fauci to charlize theron to cory booker
in their late night talk show it's
called jesus and marrow so it airs on
showtime which is a division of viacom
cbs
yay their upcoming episode features what
they call the el
i think it's a great illustrious guest
that's what they call their guests
former president barack obama here's a
preview
let me just say that i saw some of the
footage
of y'all with booker yeah yeah yeah yeah
and uh uh before you say anything that
was a deep fake and fake news yes it was
if you post that video on twitter it
will be disclaimed and there'll be a
little note on about what i'm saying
here's here's the good news looks like
y'all could play for the knicks
wow wow wow
that was a fun interview thanks for
talking all right good luck with your
little book
sit down what are we going to talk about
that's awesome oh my god jesus and mary
jones romero did you just say
barry with the rim did you just say that
when you were talking to barack obama
that is that is uncle barry
uncle berry let me just say he's got
very strong cool uncle vibes
just to see the three of you in the room
together i have to say
just really made me smile and i wonder
what it was like for the two of you to
get the interview with him because
listen
you're known for your intelligence your
authenticity
also known to be a little raw and
raunchy did you tone it down for the
president of the united states or did
you just say we're just going to be
us how did that go you know what we were
just going to just be us
we just we just did not be us a battery
excuse me
president obama respected it you know we
were very comfortable with him it felt
like
we felt like three uncles at the table
with thanksgiving just topping it up
after dinner
and we definitely could have gone in
like eight more hours talking to
obama well i mean could you do eight
more hours because the book is what 800
pages again
kept pointing out how long it was did
you learn anything new in the
conversation i'm very curious well that
that was something that we uh we kind of
highlighted because he's done so many
interviews everywhere else that we
wanted to make sure that we got fresh
material and asked him new questions
that he hadn't been asked already
so that was kind of the hard lifting
part of the interview i know
so what did you come up with because i
wonder about that too because he has
been everywhere but
it's like that jay-z song where they say
you could have been anywhere but you're
here with me the fact that he came to
see you all means that he likes to play
that he likes what you do and that he
wanted to participate with you so i
think that speaks
volumes about your show and what you all
mean so what did you come up with that
we haven't heard but i mean that what
did you come up with that we haven't
heard before and i know
it's coming up sunday but you can give
us a little sneak
anything surprises basketball he's a
huge basketball fan
i mean well that's not surprising we
know that joelle already
we know he loves basketball basketball
no he's obsessed with basketball like
obsessed like he can name free agents
that are on the market
like that level of obsession not like a
casual basketball fan
i like you know i'm a bulls fan i like
the bulls
he's like did you know that uh i'll say
uh ben gordon uh retired with uh 30
points averaging uh
every day you know i'll say i'll say
this much we didn't get a clear answer
for uh
are there aliens so that's the one
regret he didn't come clear on that one
so you're working with me i'll tell you
guys later round two
you're working with pepsi this holiday
season about giving back i think this is
great you're known as the bodega boys
what did you do
on behalf of pepsi we uh you know
took care of a fellow named juan who
runs jjn grocery in the bronx
which is like a staple a hub of the
community and
uh they covered his entire rent for
2021.
yes wow and that's it was super
important because
we so people it was a selection process
we found so many different bodegas and
the bodega we found the owner his father
actually died from covid earlier this
year
so he took some time off and had to come
back and reopen
his store so pepsi found a way to give
back because the bodega give back and
paying his rent
for a year just gives him a peace of
mind to keep him open because you know
bodegas are the lifeblood of the
community and that's where everyone's
getting their food from right now
yeah you make the point that i was going
to make if you don't live in new york
city you may not realize that a bodega
is on every corner in new york city and
they are what anchor
a neighborhood and those bodega owners
they put up with some hard times and
people give them a hard time sometimes
because
they're open 24 hours and you know in
the middle of the night things get a
little bit wild
uh so yeah that's a big deal that gives
[Music]
yeah to give something back to someone
like juan
you two have you two have had a youtube
had a really big year
i mean you've got it's just the barack
obama interview since the latest
you had a best-selling book which you
were on with us uh before
uh earlier in the year about and you've
got a shoe partnership now with
timberland
this is that chew collection over your
shoulder with shortcutting in my son's
brain
yeah and uh and your show's been renewed
for another season so what's the
highlight for you guys
right now oh man i would say the
highlight is being able
being able to make the show during the
pandemic and bring people entertainment
and some levity
because you know it's just like right
now there's no real normal but just
being able to just have our show on
twice a week and people can laugh with
us and just get their minds off of
what's going on in the world
having people come up to us and be like
yo your show is doing so much for my
mental health yeah that's like the
highlight of the year
that outweighs everything else that's so
true and before you go mara i'm i'm
curious about both of you when you were
getting ready for obama
were you a little nervous did you have
to spend time about
questions you're going to ask and what
you're going to wear i would love to
have been a fly on the wall
while you were getting ready at home
with your wife and your children the
same with you jesus that's the answer
listen from it was like the eight mile
scene when he's getting ready to
do the battle he was like right here in
the bathroom about to puke that that was
the first time i've ever had to give
myself a pep talk before i interview
what did you say so cool that we're
sitting
yes but i'd be remiss if i didn't give a
shout out to howard university would let
us film there and they made it super
comfortable it felt like a home game so
shout out to
yeah yes i was wondering where you guys
shot and that you shot him in person
bravo guys barbo
you guys got a season three of your show
coming up and i hope there'll be an
appearance number three on cbs this
morning in 2021 come back any time
yes jesus
you can watch jesus and marrow on sunday
and thursday nights on
showtime a division of viacom cbs